i have a very
uh mixed reaction
to blm because on the one hand
the idea of blm resonates with me and
has from the beginning my family has a
long-standing
understanding that there is a chronic
problem
for people of african descent in
in america and that that demands
a solution and so i also believe that
black lives are chronically
undervalued in the us and that that
is something that can change and must
change
so at the level of the the label
i'm on board but at the level of what i
discover as i try to get closer to blm
i'm frequently horrified by some of the
things that the
organization at least seems to be about
and it sounds like
your chapter is one where frankly
i would have been welcome and i might
have felt
at home is that fair you would you would
have had a seat right next to me
you wanted um i would say and i tell
people this
because and i guess we'll get to that
later but i did kind of publicly
in a way kind of announce
my i'm just seeing i guess you can say
myself away from the national blm
of 2021 but i will tell you
this i feel like there's been phases of
blm there's like
we were in the phase i believe from like
2013 to about 2017
of its most like organic state
like when it was about anti-police
brutality which i think any american
should be for because it benefits
everyone
and um and
then there was 2018 was a particular
time i think that was like phase two
of it of me even looking at it when i
was at the last year of
leaving my blm i started looking at the
national blm and i was just kind of like
something's off but i i internally was
questioning i wasn't outwardly like
saying like let's
get in front of this because it wasn't
really peaking but just something was
kind of off this is when
robin d'angelo came out with her book
white fragility and this is when
a lot of other things were happening and
i saw that the
organization's objectives started to get
ambiguous
and kind of vague and then also
the white people participating who just
came in with good intentions of just
like we want to learn we want to listen
we want to help
and it seemed very organic it felt like
at least in our organization
in other organizations that i was
treated like a peer
at that point to 2018
i felt like in a sense that
people were were selling books and
lectures and seminars and things of that
nature
to say it's not being good intentions
not good enough
like you have to showcase how in a way
show off how anti-racist you can get
and it became a performance performative
allyship at that point where people were
more so invested in blm
to um perform allie [ __ ] whether
than to do it um to act like they
weren't a part of the problem
than fixing the actual problem that's
fascinating
so it sounds like i'm sorry i didn't
mean to interrupt you but it sounds like
you had an organization built around
what seemed intuitively
meaningful and worth pursuing locally
and you it was overwhelmed
by a perspective on racism and
anti-racism that was
being sold by big names at a national
scale
that transformed your organization
away from your what sounds like very
reasonable intentions and into a
movement in which
uh effectively whites were
uh forced to show off and to one-up each
other in order to remain in the good
graces of the
of the of the organization yeah i i
would i want to make a
point though with i'm not not to say
that that happened with every single
white person that they became this moral
monster or something like that no
um i i would say i was just seeing a
national level
with like just seeing protests and
things of that nature
and just like even on social media just
how i felt like it was a performance art
piece for people
to post an instagram photo of their arm
around a black person and being like
i'm like is that for you or for them but
for my organization i
i was pretty tight-knit with with stuff
like
i had people i had a mission i said we
invite all creeds all races this is for
respectful and safe space and i mean i
had it a very clear thing
to where you had to sign it
and if you did not abide by this went
rogue
if on social media you were
creating hostile environments within
your post or whatever
you're out so you had a a code of honor
of sorts that people had
yeah people had to sign it and i kept it
on file and i gave them a thing like it
it was it was to keep everyone
accountable
um and this is the bar it's set and you
need to stay at this bar
because if you're not you're not you are
going to
um you're off the direction and the path
that we're for
but just to pick up on the phases so the
last phase
now uh with 2019 to now with black lives
matter i feel like
with the blessing of getting a lot of
funds
and getting a lot of attention
that can actually be a disservice and i
think black lives matter
there are so many businesses after 2018
that poured into black lives matter
and then those people kind of gained
control of what was happening
that the three black women i don't feel
like had much of a voice anymore that
the money had the voice
and that i feel like blm became more of
a marketing brand
it was a way for businesses to buy into
showcase how racially tolerant they are
like netflix putting blm up or whatever
i'm like i mean i for me i could see
through i'm like you don't
i don't think you really care i think
you're just trying to save your business
and like it's almost like i'm
not gonna get like biblical but
it's almost in the sense of you know
putting
blood on your door and like the ghost
coming by and
like i don't know what's going on i
understand it but this is this don't
come in
it was kind of like just a safety net
safety guard
see blm we can't be racist and i think
that's the phase we're in
but the thing is it's not it's it's if
people aren't really
outwardly talking about this but there's
been at least
10 to 15 other black lives matter
chapters that started
when i started and started in 2014
that have come out and i believe it was
the new york times piece i'm not sure
but
there's like 10 black lives matter
chapters who called out the national blm
and said
you guys have millions of dollars and
you're not helping any of the chapters
there's still people homeless there's
people
hungry there's we want funds poured into
schools for
for black children minority children and
you guys are hoarding the money
why are you hoarding it like where is it
where's the leadership
why aren't these steps happening that
you said was going to happen six years
ago
like people were calling them out and of
course that's not really shown
on social media it's the an antithesis
to what i believe beyond was
wanting to be but now i don't recognize
this blm
like so i can't in good faith attach
myself to it anymore
into the national blm but i do support
grassroots they are also very frustrated
because they believe in the original
idea of blm
and it's almost like
they don't and and i've had these
discussions with so many people who
are not for blm at all and i and i will
have these talks with them
and they're like you know what that's
awesome that these people are doing
great work but why don't they just
change their name
like if they are so like um disgusted
what's happening right now i'm like
you know when you've done something for
six years and it's
and you've done a lot and you poured all
of yourself in it
and then you know people on the tailing
come and try to make it something
that is not you're trying to fight for
the originality of
what it's for and maybe it is a losing
game
but for me all i can do is
my work be separate but when i do see
people online
you know talking about blm they're all
marxist they're all socialists they're
all
coming i'm like really all of them
like a few people say it and then
everyone
says that's everybody um but then on the
same end
they wouldn't want to be generalized by
what they believe in either
um so i try to be
a bridge i guess because even though
i i might go to a blm
protest as a journalist as someone like
to
report about what's happening but i
haven't
done like you know blm work since
the end of 2018 but i do
champion the grassroots that are still
out there feeding people doing all the
things that they can do
that you'll never know about because
they're not in it for the clout
they don't care about the attention
they're doing it because they care about
black lives mate care about what's going
on in america
and they cannot stand it when they see
other blms and i believe it was in
washington dc
where they're telling white people put
their hands up and say you're
if you don't you're a white premise and
and the funny thing is most those people
were white
right so i actually called that out on
twitter i said
if the national blm if you don't
denounce this behavior
you are tainting your organization and
the people who did this
majority of them were white so you guys
don't care about black lives
at all because when this comes out in
the articles
and they see a blm told white people to
put their hands up or the white
supremacists
no one's going to think i wonder if
they're white no they're going to assume
horse that they were black and they
actually majority
of them weren't yes this is a pattern
i have seen as well many times that
there is this
um large number of white people some of
them i'm sure think they're doing the
right thing maybe most of them
but um it's very destructive and you
know
the bill doesn't necessarily go to them
um
there are a couple points i wanted to
make just before they get lost here
your point about businesses putting up
black lives matter signs and things
my wife heather calls that a don't hurt
me wall
right and we see them all over the place
in portland here and
really once you start seeing them that
way it changes
your understanding of what's going on
you know that power is being wielded
right and um anyway it's a
it's it's very important not to take
those signs at their word some of them
may mean what they say
and some of them do not mean what they
say they're
really about fear and
it's not healthy